well if you want a tropical getaway you
might want to listen up southwest is
adding more flights
to hawaii the airline is adding non-stop
routes from las vegas to maui starting
this sunday flights to kona will be
available beginning september 7th
we spoke to the vice president of
southwest today who says connecting
hawaii to las vegas or the 9th island
as it's known was a no-brainer
we've been adding new destinations to
las vegas over the last
few months because it was still popular
during the pandemic
and now that's fully open it's even more
popular so we have non-stop flights from
uh santa barbara palm springs chicago
o'hare
houston intercontinental fresno colorado
springs bozeman montana
all just added in the last a handful of
months
southwest airlines began offering
non-stop flights from las vegas to
hawaii on june 6
but added more destinations because of
high demand watterson also tells us the
airline
prides itself on having low fares and
surviving the pandemic
with no staff layoffs